a while back I made a promise someday
I'll make a video about this whole messy
debacle so today I intend to make good
on that promise here we go
[Music]
this line is weird
it's not a border but I guess it kind of
is it divides something if it's Monday
evening and you fly from Hawaii to New
Zealand you'll cross into Tuesday
evening and then back into Monday
evening and then back into Tuesday
evening and because you've been flying
for a while now it's probably Wednesday
morning you just jumped from Monday to
wednesday on a nine-hour flight better
yet
jump in your boat on a Tuesday afternoon
and go a few hundred kilometres south
and suddenly you're watching the sunset
on a Monday because you drove South in
your boat
wait what so I want to understand this
line so naturally the first thing I do
is go into After Effects and try to map
it out as I scoured the internet for
good data on this I realized that
everyone's international dateline
is slightly different from Google Maps
to the CIA Factbook to the Pacific
Island ocean observing system which is
an organization that has the elegant
acronym of [ __ ] use [ __ ] use anyway I
spent the day scraping all the data I
could and trying to map this line looks
like it's 195 miles or around preneur
kilometers that's a huge difference
there are entire islands with people
that Google says are on one side and
[ __ ] use say are on the other who's
right here before we settle that I want
to dig into what this line even is and
why it looks the way it does
[Music]
okay so this whole crossing a line and
passing over a day and going back in
time and all of that is a little bit
hard for an O my brain to get around and
I imagine that a lot of you came to this
video hoping that you will leave this
video with a firm grasp of what the
International Dateline is so I'm gonna
delve in and explain it the best I can
first let's look at the earth from top
down so we're looking at the earth from
above like top down
here's Great Britain over here and of
course we've got our beautiful sun
shining light onto our earth which gives
us day and night land that is rotating
into this light is Xena sunrise land
that is transitioning out of this light
is seen a sunset and it's the
relationship to this light that we
measure our time with with noon being
the point where we are right smack dab
in the middle of the sun's light so
right now it's noon in Florida okay you
already know this but I'm setting it up
here because it helps the date line make
sense let's go back to Britain which is
upside down right now because remember
we're looking down on the globe like
we're looking down at the North Pole
also this circle is pretty sloppy let's
clean it up and make it a nice square so
you can keep your eye on it it's
important because all time is measured
from here technically in a little
Observatory called Greenwich so let's
say here in London it is the middle of
the day on a Monday okay so it's noon on
a monday the sun is shining right on
London don't let's freeze time and look
what's happening a few thousand
kilometers east of here in the middle of
Russia it's 6:00 p.m. the Sun is setting
it's still Monday but it's the Sun is
setting on Monday at this same moment
frozen time over here in East Asia
we've got China and there's
pan it's still noon in London remember
that but it's late over here the Sun has
gone down it's 9 p.m. in Japan it's
still Monday it's just late the Sun went
down hours ago these people are
finishing Monday it's like the middle of
the night on Monday it's noon in London
let's zoom out and realize that it's
Monday all around the world the more
west you go from London it is actually
earlier on Monday east of London it's
late on a Monday night like we just saw
it's later and later the more East you
go this is the International Dateline it
divides whether or not it's late on a
Monday night or early on a Monday
morning now let's press play on the
globe and watch it rotate into a new day
remember that these guys right here are
like at 11:00 p.m. basically midnight
they're about to start Tuesday I'll keep
Monday as this orange circle and I'll
use green for Tuesday ok press play
[Music]
okay stop zoom in here in the middle of
the Pacific it's almost 11 a.m. on
Tuesday right you're 12 hours ahead of
Greenwich Mean Time in London go right
over this line and you'll still be
around 11 a.m. the Sun is still shining
in the same way but now you are 12 hours
behind Greenwich Mean Time but it's
still Monday you're 12 hours behind
Greenwich it hasn't passed into a new
day yet and that's how you're able to
cross this line and go back a day or
forward a day even though you only go a
few hundred kilometres okay I'm sure
you're tired of looking at this top-down
globe it's kind of disorienting and not
super intuitive so let's see what this
looks like on a map on a regular old map
here we are in the same exact scenario
it's around 11:00 a.m. right here
and yet it's Tuesday here and Monday
over here I'm gonna call this side which
is later than London's time it's east of
London the Tuesday side and I'm gonna
call this side which is behind London or
west of London the Monday side I'll just
use that that's my own little
terminology imma start using that and no
one else uses it like that but I'm just
going to for the rest of this video okay
I'm interrupting all of this conceptual
non-intuitive stuff for a little
intermission I want you to just look at
this for a second there are a bunch of
beautiful islands in the Pacific
this one's called pukaki that's really
what it's called
that was my best accent just remember
that the International Date Line
runs through some of the most beautiful
ocean in the world and it's worth just
looking at it for a second
[Music]
so let's keep going on this question of
why it's different on every map why does
this line look so messed up and what's
with this knotch
and why can't anyone agree on what it
should look like this is the part that I
knew nothing about and it's fascinating
technically according to our little
conceptual model that we just did the
line should just be like this a straight
line that's on the exact opposite side
of the world as Greenwich meaning
Greenwich is zero this would be the
hundred and eightieth meridian but as
i've said many times before nature isn't
super good at straight lines so instead
it looks like this it starts out
following 180 at the meridian as it
should then it splits off right here to
make sure that this Russian island and
then the very eastern tip of Russia
don't get sliced into two become part of
different days as it accommodates Russia
it passes right here between Russia and
Alaska if you zoom in you'll see that it
passes right through these two islands
these islands are just a few kilometers
away from each other
the Sun sets at the same time on both
these islands they're right next to each
other the difference is the Sun is
setting on a Tuesday here and on a
Monday here after Russia the line heads
back west to meet up with one hundred
and eightieth but it passes it in order
to keep all of these islands on this
side because they belong to Alaska this
notch it goes all the way over to
accommodate this island of Alaska which
is this tiny outpost of 21 people it
looks like the most western part of the
United States but really because it's on
the other side of the hundred and
eightieth Meridian everything left of
this line is actually in the eastern
hemisphere so this is technically the
easternmost part of the US but whatever
it doesn't really matter it's all these
are all fake lines anyway okay so we've
zigzag back and forth crossing 180th
Meridian a few times to accommodate
Russia and the United States it finally
gets back onto the hundred and eightieth
and starts following it south for a
really long time once it gets to the
equator we begin the big game of whose
side are you on all these islands in the
Pacific and there are loads of them have
to make a decision on
whether or not they want to be the first
people to start new days or the last
people to end those days we've got this
big notch here which basically exists to
accommodate Cuddy boss which is an
island nation of just like a hundred and
twelve thousand people but this nation
is spread across a huge swath of ocean
which spans an area greater than the
continental United States it's huge it
bounces around here to make sure that
Cuddy bus is on the eastern hemisphere
time zone with Australia and Asia and
that other nations like the Cook Islands
are on the western part like with the
United States it dips down here between
Samoa which is on the Tuesday side and
the islands of American Samoa which are
on the Monday side same with the United
States from here the line heads straight
south but not along the hundred and
eightieth like it should instead it
follows closer to like 170 second this
is meant to allow a bunch of these
island nations to stay in the tuesday
side so that they can be on the same
date as big regional countries like
Australia or New Zealand then finally it
meets up with one hundred and eightieth
meridian and it follows it all the way
down to Antarctica okay so that is this
line and why it exists and why it
zigzags and all of its twists and turns
so our two important questions here why
does it look so weird and why is it
different on every map the first one we
can kind of answer pretty easily after
seeing where the line goes which is this
line is really flexible it's not a real
border it doesn't denote any land that
somebody owns a regular border is
defined through conflict or negotiation
and it denotes the sovereignty of a
country you own this and I own that that
is what a normal border does this
doesn't do that the dateline is a
decision that every country can make for
itself
[Music]
when they're in the Pacific they can
decide oh I want to be on the same date
as Australia and Japan or I want to be
on the same date as Hawaii and the
United States that is a unilateral
position that no country has to
negotiate with others to make the
Pacific nation of Samoa has decided it
would be better off if it observed a
time zone closer to that of Australia
and New Zealand so its declared it will
switch to outside of the International
Dateline before that big notch existed
half of cut Abbas was in the tuesday
side and the other half was in the
Monday side which just made it really
hard where was like Friday on this side
and if people wanted to get in touch
with people in their country it was
already Saturday on their side and so
they were off for the weekend so they
unilaterally decided in 1995 to just
change the line and put the entire
country on the Tuesday side so every
country decides how they want to do it
and because of that it's changed
dramatically over the years as countries
just make their own decision on what
date and time zone they want to be in so
now to my second question and the big
one that I was very curious about which
is who's right after a day of fixating
on this question and mapping and doing
all this stuff on the computer it all
came down to this moment you have these
two versions of the notch that are
different the black one is Google Maps
this is how Google Maps displays it on
all of their different platforms and
this yellow one is from that Pocky used
the Pacific Observer something I don't
really remember but it's like a big
Authority for the Pacific Ocean remember
that this is the Monday side and this is
the Tuesday side same time different
dates as I zoomed around this I saw
these I
Google says that these islands are on
the Tuesday side the one day ahead side
whereas [ __ ] use says that these are on
the Monday side meaning the one day
behind side
I checked the official time zone for
every one of these islands and
discovered that they all belong to the
Cook Islands which is a set of island
connected to New Zealand but that is on
GMT - ten mean it's ten hours behind GMT
not a bunch of hours in front of GMT in
short all of these islands on Monday
side packy use has it right and Google
Maps has it wrong wait why does Google
Maps has something wrong bit of an
existential crisis I've been going
through the past couple of days I want
to be wrong on this in fact if somebody
comments and points out a flaw in my
logic or my analysis here I will be
grateful for that because this is
something that I mean I have a really
deep appreciation for Google Maps and
all of the wonderful mapping that they
do but I think they got this wrong
somebody proved me wrong please and if
not my worldview has just shifted
slightly but here's the thing at the end
of the day it doesn't really matter the
fact that Google Maps didn't
painstakingly weave its line through all
of these islands is kind of an
indication that these borders these fake
borders these lines don't actually do
anything besides describe the preference
on how different countries want to
measure their time doesn't give anyone
extra land it doesn't give anyone extra
waters or minerals or any of the stuff
that usually make lines really important
in this case we're describing a
preference and so I'm sure that these
mapping organizations haven't cared too
much about getting the shape perfectly
in this vast swath of ocean that is
mostly uninhabited dad's the
International Dateline
I want to hear thoughts and feedback
from everyone and
thank you for watching so I've been home
a lot lately you probably have been to
and I've been watching a lot of Netflix
and a lot of other stuff and one thing I
realized is that there are a lot of
shows and movies on Netflix that I don't
have access to because I'm in United
States Lord of the Rings for example
that's where a VPN comes in expressvpn
specifically the one I use there the
sponsor of today's video if you don't
know what it bpn is it is a service that
allows you to encrypt your connection to
the internet so that your data is secure
and all of your connections and what
you're looking on the Internet is secure
but it also allows you to route your
connection through whatever country you
want so I'm sitting there on Netflix and
I want to watch Lord of the Rings
suddenly I can connect through Canada
and now Lord of the Rings is available
on Netflix expressvpn allows you to
expand your entertainment options while
also keeping any work that you do online
private and secure so it's a great
product I've been using it for a year as
well before they came to me to sponsor
video and because they sponsor this
video you can get three months of free
service when you sign up for a yearly
subscription if you go to expressvpn com
slash Johnny Harris go route your
connection through the UK and watch Rick
and Morty on Netflix it's pretty cool so
anyway expressvpn comm / Johnny Harris
Thank You expressvpn for supporting this
channel and thank you for watching I'll
see you in the next one